all right we're going to begin this hour
with a question on many people's minds
these days amid all these major
developments in the field of artificial
intelligence and that question is this
how long until the machines replace us
take our jobs new systems from Google
and Microsoft Plus a Microsoft partner
called open AI they're capable of doing
things that we used to think were
uniquely human things like creating our
generating original writing and the
possibilities are truly gigantic huge
but so are the fears about our jobs and
about our wages in particular
this is replacing White Collar jobs as
artificial intelligence gets better
anyone who writes for a living has to be
concerned I mean this thing you know it
can create code job security is only
supposed to get worse and in reports
like this one of the top jobs are AI
overlords plan to kill coding or
computer programming is often on the
list click new prompt okay new chat so
with the Indulgence of Sam zonka a coder
and instructor at the general assembly
coding school in New York I decided to
test the idea of an imminent AI takeover
by seeing if the software could code for
someone who knows as little about
computers as me oops eliminating the
need to hire someone like him please
build a personal website for CBS anchor
Gail King we use the fame chat GPT famed
in part for writing code so all this
gobbledygook on the screen that's what
people who sit in these classrooms learn
yep and I for one one was prepared to be
amazed but take a look at the results
about as basic as a basic website can be
what do you think you're the
professional
and while there is more sophisticated AI
coding software out there it seems none
of it can yet replace the talent of
professional coders in fact it may
actually help them so if you could look
into the future here how do you think AI
will change the way you do your job
it'll definitely automate the more
tedious parts of it but
uh it's still a long ways away before
having a true impact hello hi Tony how
are you great to meet you Microsoft CEO
Satya Nadella is a big believer in AI
but not in the idea that AI is coming
for our jobs you think it will create
more jobs than it will take I believe it
creates more I'll call it both
satisfaction in current jobs and net new
jobs in fact when we sat down earlier
this month ahead of the launch of the
new ai-powered Bing he argued that
artificial intelligence could help the
economy across the board my biggest
worry is we need some new technology
that starts driving real productivity
it's time for some real Innovation do
you think it'll drive up wages I do
believe it'll grow up Pages because
productivity and wages are related but
while that may be true in the long run
MIT Economist David otter believes that
the rise of AI does indeed mean millions
of jobs are going to change in our
lifetimes and what's scary is we're just
not sure how we are very good at
forecasting what we will not be doing
and very poor at forecasting what we
will be doing he points out for example
that more than 60 percent of the types
of jobs people are doing today didn't
even exist in the 1940s while many of
the jobs that did exist have been
replaced what we've seen over the last
four decades in the US and many
industrialized economies is what
economists call Labor Market
polarization which means the hollowing
out of the middle set of you know jobs
that often were kind of middle-class
jobs involving Blue Collar production
and operative work but also
administrative support you know clerical
tasks you know we used to have Banks and
banks of people who answered phones who
did typing and filing who reproduced
documents who kept tables of books many
many of those things are now done by
machines so when you say the job market
has been polarized the last four decades
you mean technology has come along it's
punched a hole in all these middle
skills old jobs and the people who used
to be here have some have gone up here
and made more money but a whole lot of
them have gone down here and they're
making way less and that's where the
pain happens that's especially where the
pain happens that also troubles Meredith
Whitaker who co-founded the AI now
Institute to study how all these new
systems of artificial intelligence will
affect our lives they don't replace
human labor they just require different
forms of Labor to sort of you know
babysit them to train them to make sure
they're working well whose work will be
degraded and whose you know house in the
Hamptons will get another Wing I think
that's the fundamental question when we
look at these Technologies and ask about
questions about work by degrade you mean
yeah you still have a job but it's not
the job you used to have yeah yeah but
you better move Apartments because
you're not going to be able to afford
the rent anymore
but back at general assembly at a recent
open house all that worry seemed far
away as we watched a new generation of
hopeful students sign up to learn how to
code come what may on a scale of one to
ten how worried are you as a coder about
AI
at this moment in time
two a two
but the problem is that I'm not entirely
sure if the AI that would replace me is
10 years from now 20 years from now or
five years from now
so he's not worried I wanted to give
people some practical takeaways okay so
for the future for kids they're gonna be
fine there's going to be jobs in the
future people are going to have jobs in
the future right if you're working right
now and you're worried what's going to
happen to your job you got to think
about how what you do can complement
rather than compete with these AI
systems that's what the economist at MIT
says and also Meredith Whitaker uh what
she points out is it's time now to
organize if you're a worker go to
management as a group and use your voice
to shape how your company buys these
systems and implements them otherwise
you know you're going to be receipt on
the receiving end as opposed to in the
driver's seat and you're responding as
opposed to being proactive absolutely
they're saying do that just like
anything else when it comes to
competition it probably works if you
study what AI is doing well yeah and
having an understanding what it does
that you can possibly and don't
necessarily Panic you see these lists of
all the jobs are going to be eliminated
we're not very good at making those
predictions right things happen in
different ways than we expect and you
could actually find an opportunity to
make more money if you figure out how
you can complement the machine as
opposed to get replaced by this Nadella
from Microsoft seemed to set it up as a
value add not a value long term he's a
the research suggests he is correct in
the long term more jobs more money it's
in the short term where all the pain
happens and I was hoping to give people
some guidance in what to do right this
moment how to feel that was good yeah
that was real good